two hardwood magicians who are forever
linked by a draft day trade now we're
not talking about the best nba player
we're talking about the best highlights
luka doncic taking on trey young
who has the better highlights we'll find
out right now
101. this episode's categories are best
shake and bake
most clutch most creative which is our
surprisingly great category
best game winner and best fake out this
episode of one on one is presented by
state farm when it comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent for a surprisingly great
rate with state fund
i'm your host christian crosby and to
co-host the show with me you know this
guy very well he's an nba vet and
podcast legend that's right i said he's
a podcast go
make some noise for quentin richardson
what's up q i'm here man let's get it
cracking i'm ready
all right and to help us make this
happen we have a goat in the building
and you know i love calling everyone
goats but this is actually a real life
goat
this man is the ncaa champion and 88
champion i'm so many other things in the
game of basketball y'all better give it
up
for jason the jack
terror love all love one on one baby
let's get it
definitely a dope match up you got two
young superstars in our league
two showmen of the game so it's only
right there when they go head-to-head
in a one-on-one battle right here all
right the first category
is the best shake and bass oh oh
oh god come on come on see
that type of stuff you do jack when
y'all know y'all got a big man out there
on you and you
all know i'm about to do something him i
ain't one time made enough i'm across
him two three times look at that that
was like
four crossovers bro if i'm the marcus
man i'm mad at the whole team you knew
this man had me in a situation when he
had me in it
until the market drone fought he ran up
he ran up on the hot saw he said you
know big me and you he stayed back and
making sure to jump he ran up
marcus knew the job was dangerous when
he took it look at the humble grin he
does as he runs back though after he did
him dirty like you trying to act like
you know like
i'm not bad but nothing was humble about
that green
stop it
nothing about that green that green
would just let them know
one i got one lucas clip right here
i love luca oh
oh oh oh it wasn't any secret that he
was going left
step back no see no i'm just saying the
way he made him
face his whole body twice he jumped from
different spots twice look
one two oh yeah then you try to die you
can't recover after that
how does that feel when that happens to
you like when that shot goes
in and you defend it i mean i've been on
the end of both
ends right it ain't a good feeling but
i'll tell you one thing i'm trying to
get you
right back i don't know that i've been
hit with that many moves in the road
without
fouling somebody i'm pretty sure that if
i got hit
that many times then i'm gonna grab or
i'm gonna do something cause that was
because at that point you showing out
and i'm gonna feel some type of way
about that
i know i didn't probably got hit one
time with a bomb real quick
but not a bomb bomb bring me back then
bomb again and bomb right now i'm
fouling before i left
that lucas step back three was like
absolutely ridiculous but the way
trey just kind of went one two he gave
him a four piece chicken wing
and then served him a biscuit two at the
end so i'm i'm gonna have to go with my
guy
trey on this one he crossed him about
three four times man i got i got to go
ice tray on this one man luca's play was
absolutely filthy too but i i
listen this one you know the big fella
ran up
you know it it went downhill from there
yeah i gotta go you know my dallas fans
are gonna hate me my mad fans for life
don't hate me but
i straight a gang man he brought back
some old steve free
franchise memories when they used to run
a play called one shake
and he used to just dance dance dance
dance
and then leave you and finish on you so
i straight again
gets the win for me on this one ice tray
across the board
in this category i i'm not mad at it
that clip that clip was just dirty it
was nasty so that that's the easy one we
can move on to
that he put a bow on it with the little
slide grin running back that was the bow
tie that was
that was it right there all right next
category shout out to y'all because
y'all have always been clutch this one
is called most
clutch let's see what trey does first oh
no not against my boys in philly
three seconds left in the game oh no not
against my poison philly
get your flotation device out that's
tough
lebron all right let's take a look at
this luca clip
oh 0.6 yeah 0.6.6 seconds left
with 0.3 or more you can catch and shoot
and i was watching this game
live i'm telling you this was a year
yeah watching it live
and dame had just hit a shot and then
luca magic
struck i mean i don't even know if you
could see it but the ball goes outside
the frame and then just
drops out the sky look at that
game time and that's a practice shot in
practice that's like a trick shot in
practice when you're shooting around and
you've got to put a few seconds and you
stand and put your feet
on the very edge of the line that's
that's what that was that he just did
in the game for the game see i don't
know if you all know my rap sheet but i
thought every shot i shot was going in
it didn't matter oh we know we know what
time it is
i think it's very this is the easy one
y'all i think this shot
right here don't make no sense this he
was blessed by the gods of basketball in
this moment they sprinkled their magic
on this man
and he just threw it up and it just went
in i gotta give it to my man luke on
this
yeah i'm gonna give it to luca because
time is scored .6
and then look where he did it in foreign
territory on the road
toughest place to get a win in portland
uh
i'm going with luca on this luca magic
strikes again
cute do we have another clean sweep on
this he's falling out of bounds with
commandos behind the backboard
he gotta win luca man
clean win for luca these boys going head
to head it's looking like it's lining up
pretty good right now
all right so this next category is most
creative this is when a play
looks like it's not going so well but
then ends up being surprisingly
great let's start with trey here we go
that was disrespectful i don't that's
disrespectful but this went exactly as
he wanted
to go he meant to do that he hit the
cleanest how you feel about that jay
that's the little man going in there
doing that
yeah i'm trying to tell you every little
man better have some of that with him
but i'm telling you right now
bangs babes tried to clean him out
of here just in you and i played
that's what it was all about you know
showtime entertainment
and then you're definitely trying to
one-up somebody i'm and if you do
are you going to talk to him and let him
know about it so trey embodies some of
that right there some of that old school
and you know a hard foul was coming from
cute rich if you tried to show him up
yeah q's made that a very clear right
that's where i got threw off i didn't
know whether he lost a ball of wood
here's what i don't understand this
man's got eyes in the back of his head
how in the world did he know
that he was back there he didn't even
look back he saw him when he did the
little hesitation in the middle that's
that was when he surveyed everything
that's what make it so nice right
right right
it's just mathematics i mean you got
four white jerseys yeah let me just
throw this behind me somebody in blue
gots to be open
yo that's crazy man that was that was
when they say eyes in the back of your
head right there it's a tough one for me
right here this is tough
you always like a helping hand man and
luca involved his teammates on that one
he took on four defenders
i'mma go with the home team i got to go
with the dallas man
all right cute we got we're gonna save
you the last queue we're gonna save you
for last
you going luca i'm gonna try i'm doing
it just for the sake of the show baby
i'm going for the show i'm putting this
on you
you're gonna put me in the slings yeah
you see i'm already saying it's hard
[ __ ]
yeah i got i gotta go with ice tray on
this one
he's a little man first he didn't he boo
boo ruby yo he said i'm a little rubio
look how rubio turned around like what
just happened to me he ain't even move
after the play like he
done he tried like he out of the play
then um
and hit the hit the hit the big man bang
the giant killer and you get the elbow
drop off tyrosine
look at him both i'm on the ground he's
looking at baines over there he like
yeah and one
this was a one-man show by ice tray like
you know luca went with the assist and
it was like
i felt like this trey did more because
he took the big the big hit from baines
and he still
finished with the you know every little
dude love that play any little dude is
going to see this play going to
appreciate it because the big dude
always come to knock him out
so he he rescind my boat i'm rescinding
my vote i'm going with ice trader gang
and y'all got something against portland
man because luke could keep doing
portland dirty stuff
we gotta find another team for him to do
bad so ice tray
is up whoa ice straight coming through
with another clean sweep out of nowhere
taking that edge on luca and the matchup
went in the most creative category
i gotta clap up for my guy for doing
that that never happened on the one on
one show
i think my explanation showed him the
ways though you know like the
mandalorian this is the way like i
showed them this was the way
yeah you did you could talk me right
into it
all right next category is best game
winner it's self-explanatory let's check
this right now
the game winner versus milwaukee
no time left oh my god
that's crazy end of the giants jt he
went in there where he don't belong and
gotta put
i'm already skeptical on this one
already yeah
ah that's just look that's that's
you see the flex though the legs first
to let y'all know
i'm i'm big in here
y'all gotta put the disco lights back
you throw them disco lights behind you
might think it's el debarge out there
for a minute
all right here's luca this is a playoff
game winner right here so
it's already oh my goodness come on
bubble buzzer
whoa
that's playoff basketball right there
hey listen i'm telling you right now
this one ain't no competition
listen you said it this is the playoffs
and then this is like you said before
this is a one-man
show look at how this man did it he this
is like mark jackson say man i have this
dance who's that reggie that's dang
reggie i remember that too look at how
reggie just stopped there was nothing
you could do
and then once again you got luca walking
off like i
i i'm not surprised i do this i expected
that to happen
but look at carlyle now man you got a
slo-mo carl out carla like
[Laughter]
just like i drew it up now you know you
didn't draw up
and cross over it step back as he pull
up you did not draw that up
that's the part for me that makes it so
impressive the fact that
reggie bit on every move and then he hit
him with two more
to kill him the first one he there with
him he there with him but he moving his
body with everyone when he hit him with
that last
bob step back here over there and his
curtains just like
god grease i'm not running around like
ah i'm surprised like nah
this is like i just i just did them that
was a that was a bull's-eye from 2000
feet out i just yeah
like i'm an assassin i know i'm on the
coaches but look at doc
they bent you over doc look at it
yeah doc ain't guarded one move out
there look at it he looked tired he's
hit
he couldn't do nothing about it hey look
at the world doc as a coach huh
wore him out that was dirty
that man strikes again man and luca
magic he gets my vote i ain't changing
this one cute
we can't change on this one it ain't
nothing to change my brother it ain't
nothing to change
real i'm gonna go next to you i
feel like i gotta get this to try i
straight just like pull this out of
nowhere
i'm giving it to ice cream i i feel like
he deserves this one
really wasn't no skill i ain't did the
tip drill since fourth grade you know
i don't know man we all did it that's
all that is that tip thrill man come on
now
but what luca did start to finish like
that was one of the plays like when i
grew up watching mj when he got the ball
you knew me
everybody in the building knew he was
getting the ball he got it and he
delivered then he not only delivered but
he turned around looking at everybody
like this is what i was supposed to do
and i knew i was going to do it
got to respect that
i'm not even mad at it i'm not even mad
at it lucas got the w for the game
winner category it was a beautiful shot
it was a beautiful play all the way
through
and ladies and gentlemen we are clean
slate tied once again it's tied up
oh we jammed up we jammed up baby we got
one more category
i'm loving how this is panning out last
category in this episode of one-on-one
is best fake out let me remind you we
are neck to neck
this is the finals this is the last
match up here two hardwood magicians
going head to head to see who's going to
win let's see what happens here we go
oh oh oh he faked me in the camera out
on that one
wait a minute he faked me and the camera
i don't know
hey oh come on yeah i thought
the original clip body had dropped it
behind the back
houdini with the rock he did that's a
whole lot right there on the handle side
i didn't have none of that with me i had
none of that
only in the summertime yeah in the game
oh
no see that's what i've been waiting to
see right yeah he slapped michael porter
junior on the butt like good d
watch watches that's the biggest
disrespect watch this right here he gave
him the pat on the butt like yeah good
try like huh
look
[Music]
that took me out right there
i have to look like three planes and say
wait did he
yo how did you catch that cute yo
that's wild all right i think it's time
to move on to the final luca clip that's
a tough act to follow can luca do it
let's see
he's running around
[Laughter]
yeah he's been around
it wasn't even holiday for me lopez got
fake and he wasn't even the stars he
wasn't on the ball though he's for his
i mean the best thing about it man it's
just this is just highlights this isn't
who's the better player or this so that
this is just
based on how you know i highlight you
know that's the part i love about it
luka giving you shades of larry though
when he hits you with that one it is
around that's that's larry legend stuff
right there
yes sir all right the real question is
are y'all
ready to vote
yeah i'm ready i'm ready i don't know i
don't know i don't know if i'm ready i
just want to know if y'all are ready
i'm ready see right there that's the
lasting memory i have right
if i had to just go with highlight it
seems to be the most unique
out of the two and it's hard to say that
because trey i mean goodness gracious
houdini
this man's over here doing magic tricks
on the court but i think
it it's hard it's hard it's hard for me
to say but i gotta go with luca on this
one
gotta look
i'm going with trey for the full body of
work
right he had to dance fever at the
beginning
then he went behind the back between the
legs to himself
and then the love town
solidified the deal hey listen
i think we gonna have to officially
can't change change his name from ice
tray to trade the bars because he's
doing a whole lot of dance moves out
here man
this is what did it for me when he came
down on the first clip
and he came and went back here i thought
he had dropped the ball to the top of
the key with a behind the back pass but
now he kept it and the man reacted that
was where the whole everything
went all right when he hit you with the
fake behind the back because everybody
just seen somebody come down and
bomb rip it behind the back and you
react to that he hit you with the wide
but came back
and that brought all the space and then
when he got there he just still did the
one-man show like jt say that
the body at work ice tray you going ice
track
ice tray
you know what that means that means ice
tray tray young is the winner of this
one-on-one competition
it's official i got to give it up to my
main eyes tray
congratulations you got to give it to
him he is the one-on-one champion it's
official
new one-on-one champion trae young well
deserved
jason terry i just got to thank you for
coming through and blessing us
[Music]
in the field and i'm gonna be with him
man just let me got you coming
you know we headband brothers we here we
go way back get
uh getting that train back right day
ones this episode was brought to you by
state farm
like a good neighbor state farm is there
you